hey everyone how are you thanks for
having me
can I answer any questions actually how
many people here have no idea who I am
raise your hand okay
[Music]
pedigree beam and a special my specialty
to having a day you talk good talk this
morning a lot of energy you know what
you can hear what I built a business or
personal brand so they can buy stuff
with it like you know that thing I said
the other day on the blog right like I
don't want to buy a private jet like
everybody tells me to do when they see
that I'm wasting an hour on an extra
commercial flight because I want to buy
the New York Jets you know what I mean
and like and so all all this behavior my
man is predicated on insecurity
you know why 24-year old dudes buy
watches because they're not confident
and they need that to get a girl
like all those dudes that are flashing
on social media I look at them like
insecure like not real confident you
know puffed up fake so you know it's the
same old thing it's the same reason
people buy followers on social guys and
some of you did it because one of the
people I looked at last night that's
here with the hashtag bought it you know
how I know you can't have 800,000
followers on Instagram and get 27
comments and 94 likes I ended my talk
with it which is the worst business is
to sell to losers and I promise you
there's a stunning amount of people here
who try to sell to the bottom feeders
and you never trick winners when people
DM me and like you'll guarantee check me
out I'm killing it and they've got nine
hundred thousand followers on Instagram
but they don't actually have it I reply
no you aren't and then their feelings
are hurt and it makes me feel awesome
holls hold your breath keep building for
the audience bring them value you know
what your next Instagram post should be
instead of taking 400 bucks for a
sponsored ad why don't your next
Instagram post be what can I do for you
guys to make this account better and
then we'd all the comments and then act
on them
got it this what kind of vibe - again
what a weird role take the different
vibes stop hiring more services coaches
people all which are disguises for you
not to actually do the work
a lot of admiration a lot love a lot of
selfies
[Music]
no such thing
a really interesting moment right now as
you guys know from the CFO episode
there's a lot going on like very deep in
my business a lot of new business we're
winning just a great day and my email
the whole Vayner
daily digital deep dive daily digital
deep done daily digital deep dive so
many of you come into vaynermedia I mean
I mean she's so exciting 97 like 10
hours at vaynermedia with all of the
practitioners in culture you know
strategy you know paid media input so
that's been fun we've sold a bunch of
seats first day so that second day's
about to sell out so that's going well
nice new business unit for us and huge
for you what else just a lot of content
I think people are too crippled by
content I call it the 14 year old
teenage move which is so many 14-year
olds
post on Instagram and then if they don't
get enough likes right away they take it
down like there are literally
fourteen-year-old teenage girls that
take an hour and a half to take a selfie
because they put it up seven times until
there's actual engagement they don't
they keep taking it down and the truth
is we all say yep yep yep and yet you're
doing it as well right you're
overthinking your content like think
about like again eating my own dog food
I believe that all content is valuable
one way or the other or it may or may
not be valuable every person here has
put up something on the internet that
has done better than they thought it
would and has done worse than they
thought it would why should you test it
it's much faster to just keep putting it
out like all the thought of testing in
and let me overthink it and then why
like everybody thinks they're gonna put
out a piece of content that's gonna hurt
you like what what is it gonna do it's
not gonna get as many likes as you like
like again way too much ego and
insecurity driving decisions let the
chips fall where they are just put out
[ __ ] content cool that's good way
about thank you
bye guys killers mom emailed us which is
insane a lot of offers and it just a lot
going on planner to the apps my TV show
a lot of just saw the media play that's
gonna be insanely to be seen a whole lot
of this space in his different forms my
neck
fixing my neck because it's new awesome
t-shirt right tortoise of it hares
costume that's me
seem fast and I am a micro fast on a
macro slow what's the score so we'd like
to welcome to the stage here Gary
Vaynerchuk and appreciate you taking
time to be here and without a whole lot
introduction I'm just gonna hand you the
mic and let him rip thanks great no
worries hey everyone how are you thanks
for having me can I answer any questions
actually how many people here have no
idea who I am raise your hand [ __ ] okay
when you incentivize somebody to do
something that is predicated on
rewarding them with something else
you're not actually getting the natural
action I hate it I hate like watch this
video or play this game and you'll get
5,000 points and then you get a [ __ ]
iPad horse [ __ ]
don't like it they all lose they all
have a run somebody exits because
whatever but nine out of ten of them
lose every time because you're creating
you're forcing behavior instead of
reacting to behavior got it alright see
ya I continue to build my brand more
than any other reason and there's a lot
of vanity that comes with it there's a
lot of financial aspects that come along
with it but I want everybody to know and
again my behavior is proven this because
I do I did it before this happened
the single biggest reason I continue to
build my personal brand is it forces me
every single day to use Instagram
snapchat Facebook Twitter YouTube tumblr
it forces me and then I become the
plumber not just the architect and
there's way too many architects in here
and there's way too many plumbers in
here and there's not enough of people
that are both 2030 2040 I live for the
year 2040 I'm not telling my chickens
I'm not reading like headlines
I'm not even incorporating this
admiration that I'm getting right now
I'm zero I'm nothing I'm [ __ ] dirt I
haven't even started I'm a kid
[Music]
no such thing
to
such thing
[Music]
Jonathan